what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking Thrones Game of Thrones
season seven is just days away so I
wanted to bring you something special
right before the premiere that way
everyone can get a good idea of what to
expect this season I reached out to some
of the greatest minds in this community
to all come together for something epic
before we get started I have to thank
every single person that was involved
and helped contribute to this video I
really appreciate that and I think
everyone listening right now is going to
really enjoy this in this video there
are over 10 character breakdowns or
predictions for this season make sure
you listen until the very end of this
video because you aren't going to want
to miss any of them so without wasting
any more of your time let's begin when
this journey of a game of Thrones first
started it was amazing to watch the
great game in all its glory from the
wall of the five kings the multiple
politics played between Varys and
Baelish all the way to the Battle of the
bastards past time has gone by and the
show was progressed the significance of
who sits on the Iron Throne has become
completely irrelevant in the face of the
growing threat north of the wall
although Cersei is clinging on to power
and Daenerys is looking to seize control
of the Seven Kingdoms
sooner or later anyone who wants to
survive will have to unite to even stand
a chance of defeating the callous night
king and his army of White Walkers and
whites he made his move on hardhome in
season 5 creating that iconic moment
between him and Jon Snow and he shocked
everyone in season 6 when he was able to
actually torch bran in one of his
visions which ultimately forced bran and
mirror to flee back to the wall so the
burning question on everyone's lips is
what will season 7 bring with the night
king he spent thousands of years
building up his army even taking on new
born baby recruits but there is still a
colossal fortification that stands in
his way a 300 mile long frozen wall
designed with the sole purpose of
stopping him from ever setting foot on
mainland Westeros whilst many people
think he will overcome this obstacle by
taking control of one of the narrative
dragons as a result of John snows
mission nor for the wall I believe that
the knight King has already obtained a
method or he knows what he must do in
order to breach the wall popular theory
suggests ever since Brown was marked
allowing the night king into the
three-eyed Ravens cave that once he
passes through the wall with mirror it
will also allow the night king and his
army to follow suit but I completely
disagree if that was the case then
Benjen stark would have either never
allowed bran to go back to Castle black
or he would have gone with them to
protect him
instead he specifically talks about the
ancient magic that was used to construct
the wall and that was-- it stands the
dead cannot pass he cannot pass I also
refuse to believe that the night King
will need to use a white dragon to
execute his plan because that would mean
the purpose of his uprising could only
be fulfilled by a stroke of pure insane
look that he would even be dependent on
being presented with such a gift at this
stage would make his campaign a complete
farce once he learns that Jon Snow has
led a company north of the wall the
night King will throw everything at him
in an attempt to crush Westeros his
greatest hope he will keep a close watch
on brunt who is probably the only person
alive who can find the answer of how to
truly defeat him but ultimately he has
his secret weapons and he is heading
towards the frozen wall and before the
season ends it will crumble and fall
hey guys this is keV the dork from
YouTube channel bridge for pump to see
this entire compilation so thank you to
Dan for talking Thrones for putting this
together let's quickly go over the Hound
and the Brotherhood without banners the
entire season seems like it's going to
kick butt but I'm really looking forward
to the storylines that these dudes will
be involved in so first of all when
people ask me which house I would be
loyal to expecting me to say the Starks
my answer is none I'd want to be one of
the free folk or if I lived south of the
wall I'd want to join up with a
Brotherhood without banners fighting for
those who cannot defend themselves as an
awesome concept and accordingly I need
my first clash of clans account beric
Dondarrion back in the day but barracks
time is running short unfortunately it's
no secret that he was raised back to
life for a sixth time after the Hound
killed him
so he's living his seventh life right
now and considering how important a
number 7 is in terms of Game of Thrones
many fans expect a 7th life to be his
last one question is will he go down
swinging or will he magically read
someone from the dead by giving them his
own life and if it happens leading
candidates are John in the Hound but
personally I wish you would raise throws
a mirror because I love throws his
character and want to see him stick
around as long as possible very
underappreciated if you all didn't know
Thor was one a bunch of melees at
tourneys off screen he's eaten being the
Hound three times granted he likes a
sword on fire with wildfire and Sandor
was afraid of fire but regardless
Thoros is a legit badass he proved this
at the siege of Pyke during the Greyjoy
rebellion as he was at first through the
breach of the walls so let's get pumped
to finally see him kick some butt in
season 7 I'm also curious if doors in
the Brotherhood will run into Melisandre
she head south and it will be cool to
see the dynamic if they were united with
Gendry whom they gave to Melisandre back
in the day I suspect that there was a
sword burning with wildfire can kill
White Walkers since wildfires made from
magical spells but I also suspect that
Barracks sword can not only kill whites
but kill White Walkers since it's not
ordinary fire it's magical in a sentence
since he lights his sword on fire from
his own magical blood he's like a dragon
fire made flesh and of course a beloved
Sandor Clegane
he's now teamed up with a brotherhood
there are a bunch of cool directions
that historic can go
Sandor and Oriya need to reunite their
dynamic rock it will also be interesting
to see what happens at him and Brienne
run into each other a second time
considering that she thinks she killed
him sander may expose Littlefinger's
betrayal
then start back in season 1 and sander
may kill his brother in Co game Bowl but
instead of doing out of anger a buddy
joseph riemann came up with a concept of
a mercy kill because for all intents and
purposes
his brother is already dead and i am
very interested in sander overcoming his
fear of fire since it will be key in
fighting the dead army but even more
importantly a personal level overcoming
his fear of fire is key to Sandor
finally releasing the demons that have
haunted him his entire life and last but
not least this one goes out to all the
sands and shippers Sandor and Sansa have
to reunite the awesome if they fell in
love but unfortunately I see sander
going down protecting sons hi everyone
for those of you who don't know us we
are the order of the green hand here to
give our season 7 predictions for the
infamous twincest duo jaime and cersei
so at first we were going to break it up
and go through Circe's predictions and
then jamie's but since for at least the
first half of the season the face of
jaime and cersei will be intertwined as
they have been since the beginning of
the show we decided to do them together
at the end of last season Jaime had just
returned to King's Landing from Ty
winning Edmure Tully into surrendering
Riverrun to find the absolute carnage
Cersei had inflicted on the city when
she blew up baler Sept on top of that he
makes his way into may course to find
Cersei crowning herself queen which
definitely didn't seem to please Jaime
on a number of levels first and most
obvious her sitting there means his last
living child is clearly dead and based
on what he saw when he arrived he's
probably at least 95% short Cersei had
something to do with Tommen's death on a
less personal level he has to know that
no one is going to accept Cersei as the
rightful ruler of the Seven Kingdoms and
her sitting her sweet little ass in that
chair
donning that crown and proclaiming
herself Queen Cersei of
Lannister first of her name queen of the
Andals the Rhoyne are and the first men
and protector of the realm is
practically a declaration of war which
she likely knows will result in him
having to fight just about everyone
especially since she didn't even use the
Baratheon name to justify her position
so where does it go from here well it's
clear from the trailers in the title of
the first episode that Dany will be
landing on Dragonstone in the season 7
premiere which I'd like to say is
Circe's biggest problem but it's more
likely that she'll be her own biggest
problem her thirst for power may have
been partially quenched
but unhinged rulers like Cersei tend to
suffer from paranoia and they've been
setting up the Maggy the Frog prophecy
as the source of what will inevitably
become Circe's downfall for a few
seasons now and with all of her children
dead there's only one part of the
prophecy that has yet to come to
fruition a valonqar now since it is
clear that Lena Headey has a contract
for season eight sir she's not going to
be killed by either of her younger
brothers this season
but that doesn't mean that the prophecy
won't be the source of her undoing as
mentioned a moment ago Jaime did not
look pleased with Circe's decision to
claim the iron throne but his love and
devotion to her hasn't failed yet so he
will likely do everything he can to try
to stop her from going completely off
the rails but Cersei at this point
likely sees Tyrion as neutralized and
therefore no threat to her where the
prophecy is concerned which leaves only
Jaime as time goes on and Jaime
questions more and more of her decisions
it is likely that Cersei will begin to
distrust him which will eventually grow
into fear that he is the Valen car in a
recent interview Lena Headey revealed
that Cersei is an absolute horrible cow
to one character in particular next
season we think this person is Jaime as
he is the only one Cersei being horrible
to would have any effect or be
noteworthy Cersei being a horrible
to everyone else is just par for the
course and the same song-and-dance we've
been watching for six seasons we see
this as the likely cause of jamie's
support for her starting to dwindle
leading to a fracture in the
relationship and his decision to head to
Casterly Rock which he absolutely needs
to do at some point because there is no
one ruling there and since he was
stripped of his white cloak last season
he is now able to become the Lord of
Casterly Rock and warden of the West now
in the books Searcy ends up writing a
letter to Jamie asking for help which he
decides to ignore I found this to be a
huge moment for Jamie of the character
because up until this point every single
decision in action he had taken revolved
around keeping Cersei happy and keeping
their secret I really hope the show goes
this route and has a similar situation
ensue where Cersei writes to him at
Casterly Rock and he ignores this
request which I think will be even more
powerful played out on-screen but how
will this season end for Jaime and
Cersei well the way we see it there can
really only be one ending for these two
given everything else that's going on in
the story Jaime as the Lord of Casterly
Rock and warden of the West joins the
Alliance of Dany
Jon the Vale the reach and Dorne and
marches north to fight the White Walkers
while Cersei rots in one of Danny's
dungeons awaiting what will likely be an
epic execution in season eight I must
admit I'm really hoping to see Tyrion
feed her to his dragon which at least in
the books he says has been a dream of
his since he was a boy
hey if grey area and I'm going to tell
you my prediction the for Tyrion
Lannister in season seven Tyrion is in
his second power position as a hand to a
king or queen his first time in such a
position he excelled greatly improved
his worth as a hand he made valuable
alliances Specht the small Council in
his favor and defended the city during
the Battle of Blackwater
arian is the nurses hand of the queen
and he will continue to provide her with
great counsel Tyrion will spend a lot of
time educating Daenerys on the different
houses of Westeros and Westeros in
general because veneris does not know a
lot about the place she's trying to
conquer
I think Syrian will act as not only her
Council but her emissary and a strategic
planner I think he will speak on her
behalf to some of the great Lords of
Westeros a big role Tyrion will play in
season seven is the taking of Casterly
Rock
I do think tyrion will come up with the
strategy to take Casterly Rock because
no one knows casually rock like tyrion
tyrion as a youth was put in charge of
the sewers and drains of Casterly Rock
and just like Lann the clever the plan
will be to sneak into Casterly Rock
through the sewers or drains and take
the rot from the inside out I do think
that tyrion is going to be conflicted at
some point in the season because he does
not like Cersei but he loves Jaime Jaime
has always been compassionate to Tyrion
in Syrian loves him and he will probably
try to get word to Jaime through a raven
or maybe personally telling him to join
his side tell Cersei to lay down her
swords or she's going to die Jaime might
join him but Cersei absolutely will
fight to the death against scenaries
it's also going to be interesting to see
how Tyrion interacts with Dorne being
thus fans makes killed marcela Tyrion
hated Joffrey but he loved Marcela and
Tommen so there might be some conflict
between Tyrion and Dorne in the chamber
of the painted table period also knows
Jon and has given Jon counsel before and
also saved him from a beatin at the wall
so in season 7 Tyrion will also act as a
liaison or a mediator between Daenerys
and Jon in season 7 I'm sure Tyrion will
be drinking lots of empty light and
knowing lots of things strategy being
one of them my one bold prediction on
Tyrion is that he is going to want to
know where Sansa is he is her husband he
may want to reclaim his wife or it may
be forced upon him in order to form an
elite
between the north and danerys tyrion is
obsessed with dragons but I feel if the
dragons get kind of out of control and
start hunting people instead of animals
as winter is here and game will be
scarce tyrion might realize the threat
that dragons bring to Westeros
I don't think tyrion will ride a dragon
this season I don't think tyrion will
find out he's a Targaryen this season
because I don't think Tyrion is a
Targaryen but we will get strategic
season 2 Tyrion
counseling Daenerys and strategizing the
best way to take Westeros until they
realize the greatest threat is north of
the wall what's the deal my people you
know this Don Tony tough lot and I'm
back at you another one and these are my
predictions for brand stock in the
upcoming season number seven of Game of
Thrones now we remember bran last season
and all the things he did and now we've
seen that bran was dropped off by his
own uncle Benjen and benjin wouldn't
leave him the horse oh no no that was
too much benjin to do for his own little
nephew he had to take off on that horse
and that force merited drag bran around
some more all right so now after this
we've seen bran the weirwood tree and
find out the truth of Jon Snow's
parentage and I think that this will be
the main theme and what's going to
happen with brand this season
so as we have seen in the clips we know
that bran stark
definitely will make his way to the wall
now at this time when he makes his way
to the wall and will inform him that
John is no longer the Lord Commander
there and everything that happened with
the Bolton's and I think at this time
word will have already spread that Jon
has won the war of the Battle of the
bastards this could be also a time where
bran does get the wheelchair that we see
later on after this brand will then make
his way to Winterfell now we must
remember that the night's king did touch
bread and left whoa I'm gonna call
Frost's kale on his arm now I know
people believe that this is what's going
to give the White Walkers the power to
destroy
the world but it does not all this does
is allow the night king to track brand
stuff because we must understand that
what the White Walkers want is to kill
the children of the force and the green
seers so they are tracking them and
that's what's going to happen so I think
that they will separate once Bram meets
what gets to Winterfell oh it's close to
it from Mirror Mirror will then head
back to her homeland and she may go
there under orders to brand to get
Howland Reed and bring him back to bred
now once a brand is done you reunited
with his family I do believe he'll get
there and Jon Snow will not be there at
this time now we do see the picture of
Sansa Stark walking slowly away from the
tree in the last trailer I think right
here bran could have taken her into the
way would himself and exposed some lives
possibly a Petyr Baelish or he took her
and showing her John's true birth and
she is not entirely know what to do with
that situation that knowing that John is
a Targaryen that he is the rightful king
of Westeros I do believe that bran
thinks by saying this that Jon will be
able to relight the realm behind them
under the Targaryen banner that's like
to say thank you for talking Thrones for
having me on your channel it truly do
appreciate it and you know who it is
peace and stay sexy so what we know from
torment so far is that he will be part
of the discussions with the northern
Lords he will interact with Brienne in
the Winterfell courtyard and he will go
beyond the wall and fight some White's
with John with that being said I think
Brienne will play a big role in torment
storyline this season they made it clear
last season that he was interested in
her and so they must want to do
something with that in the plot
especially since we got those pictures
of them together during the scene with
the northern Lords it wouldn't be too
surprising to see torment supporting
anything that Jon wants to do and also
continuing to be a good leader for the
wildlings but since Brienne is in that
scene as well I was thinking that they
may hint to his crush on her once again
maybe he will try to sound tough in
front of everyone and then sneak a look
at her
then I feel like the relationship will
evolve a bit more later when Breanna
straining Patrick in the courtyard
Harlan will probably flirt with her
there and it would be cool if we could
even see them fight each other just
something that would help torment
realize how tough Brienne actually is
kind of like what happened to her with
Jaime Wendling Chrissy said recently in
an interview that what's recurrent in
Brian's life is forming relationships
with people that start with an opposing
force then a begrudging mutual respect
and out of that a deep respect and pure
love that happens again this season
Brienne will realize that deep alliance
so I'm assuming that has to do with
torment Brienne might affect Herman in
some way that will be important when he
has to be on the wall
tormund may do something that he
wouldn't have done if it weren't for
Brienne but I also think they want to
give us a bit of a tragedy here this
relationship can't work so I'm worried
that they will end up killing one of
them it's been a big fear of mine for a
while now that Torrance n will come
during his adventures beyond the wall I
would hate to see torment die and I hope
he doesn't but if he has to go since
he's all about big large things I hope
he gets taken out by a big large thing
as well like a giant oh and I hope that
weapon that he's carrying in the
trailers does turned out to be made of
dragonglass
I would love to see him kill not only
white but at least one white Walker to
Sansa Stark has often been a polarizing
character in Game of Thrones often
conflicted between remaining loyal to
her family and indulgence in romantic
fantasies which were the product of her
upbringing throughout the series Absa
has had her childlike romantic view of
the world shattered completely and now
sits in a place where she may be
uncertain of her role with Littlefinger
whispering in her ear in season seven
Sansa may grow conflicted knowing that
Jon rules the north even though it is
rightfully her realm in the end however
Sansa will likely see through a little
Fingaz plot and slay him for his
deception possibly even fulfilling the
ghost of High hearts prophecy from a
Storm of Swords and later I dreamt that
same made again slaying the savage giant
and a castle built of snow if Winterfell
does the castle of snow could
Littlefinger be the
of the remaining Starks in Game of
Thrones Sansa is the least liked by the
audience and seems to be the least
useful in furthering the plot if any
stark were to die this season it would
be salsa we are at a point in the show
where time is absolutely crucial many
secondary characters may die this season
Sansa may very well be one hi this is
Gemma from secrets of the Citadel and
Dan has asked me to talk about the fate
of Samwell Tarly
in season seven he's asked me to keep
this brief which isn't my forte so I'll
do my best to sum this up as concisely
as possible my predictions for Sam in
season seven are that he will with the
help of archmaester Marwan find a cure
for Jorah Mormont's greyscale I also
believe he'll discover some of the
secrets regarding how to make Valyrian
steel that's not to say he'll actually
be able to pull off the feat personally
as I believe he'll be missing a few
essential ingredients if only there was
a blacksmith and some dragons to hand
and the final thing I think he's going
to find in the Citadel is information
that not only proves that John is a
Targaryen but that he isn't even a
bastard that Rhaegar and Lyanna were
married and he is legitimate I do
however feel that for a time at least
he's not going to connect all of these
dots and he'll need to have a chat with
a certain greenseer before he fully
understands the implications of what
he's found hey there everybody it's
Kevin from the Baths reductions and
today I'm going to give my prediction on
what's going to be in store this season
for the constantly miserable looking
character Jon Snow now for what we know
jon is going to have to start out the
season picking up the pieces from the
previously warring north and ask them to
unite under their new king of the north
which may be a little rocky but I'm
pretty sure he'll get that one done
pretty quickly speaking of the king of
the north title it looks like Jon has to
worry about Sansa and Littlefinger
sending up a coup of some type against
him fortunately I'm pretty confident
he'll last until the very last
episode of this whole series so this
will be worked out in way that is going
to be very favorable to him remaining as
king of the north and Littlefinger not
being around anymore now being king of
the north means that he's probably gonna
have to meet with a certain Dragon Queen
at some point probably in the second or
third episode of the season to discuss
his lands joining Daenerys aside under
what I have to predict is going to be a
marriage proposal between the two these
great forces combined are going to be
enough to defeat Circe's reign and give
the best possible chance of fending off
the White Walkers to the rest of
Westeros maybe he'll even form a
connection by the end of the season with
a certain dragon named after his Papa
Rhaegar now looking beyond the wall it
seems that John is going to be heading
north this season along with a few of
his companions for an unknown mission
this is possibly to recover bran or it's
to do more research about the army of
the Dead not totally sure on that one it
looks like this may be an opportunity
for John to confront his ultimate
importance of the series which is that a
bezoar a high or the prince that was
promised last predictions for Lord
Jonathon snow includes reunions with his
other siblings are a stark by the end of
the season and bran stark a little bit
earlier on in the season probably around
Episode five or so and lastly it
definitely appears that they're going to
tease telling who his parents are but
for some reason I don't think anyone is
going to explicitly tell him that his
father is Rhaegar and Lyanna is his
mother even though someone like brand
will be around to do it so I think one
more season of John knowing absolutely
nothing is in store well that's it for
my predictions thank you so much for
listening you can always check out my
channel on the youtube at the back
productions to hear more commentary for
me on the series hi everybody my name is
Phil the issues guy from Phil the issues
guys channel here on YouTube and I'm so
excited to be here and huge thanks for
inviting me today I'm going to be
talking about my character which is Arya
Stark now Arya is an interesting
character look at because so much of her
story has been away from the main
narrative she's been away from everyone
in her family no contact to her home and
she's been off Westeros for a while so
looking at her is interesting to think
where her characters going to go coming
on
what happened with Walter Frey at the
twins killing him and I think most
people do believe an I do as well that
she's going to eventually head to
Winterfell I think she'll get there
earlier in the season rather than later
I think when she gets back there there
will be a lot of reunions I think Aria
this season is going to be all about
reunions with different characters
initially reconnecting with her family
then maybe eventually crossing paths
with the hound and Gendry again
throughout the season that possibly
could happen as well definitely think
her and Sansa will meet and initially
have a positive reaction to each other
but it might end up getting a little
heated at times throughout but re in a
sense is going to be a crazed wolf you
can't control instead of diplomacy or
duplicitous action like someone like
Sansa has learned how to do over her
time since they've been split Arya is
just going to act and if anyone tries to
lay any seeds of discontent throughout
the stark family like someone like a
little finger for instance I don't think
Arya is going to hesitate to act and
just stop those people she's not gonna
listen to anybody she's not gonna listen
to john king of the north she's not
gonna listen to Sansa she's not gonna
listen to brand she's gonna do whatever
she feels like she has to do to help
House Stark I also think it's going to
be really fun this season to watch her
learn about the events about what all
the other characters have gone through
and as she discovers who's alive who has
past who's gone it's going to be just
fun to see things through Arya's eyes
see some of those events for the first
time again and this last one may be more
of a want than to think but I gotta
believe that now is finally the time
I've talked a lot about reunions
reconnecting there's one last reunion to
go and that's right I do think this is
the season that we finally get the
reconnection between Arya and I'm area
and I do think we'll see the wolf pack
and will serve as a parallel between
Arya reconnecting with her Wolf Pack the
stark family not to mention if she does
meet up with bran again it wouldn't take
him too much time he could just take a
little time out of his schedule battling
the night king to just do a little bit
of a LoJack wolfing kind of situation a
direwolf LoJack situation and figure out
where the hell nightmare
is it wouldn't take too much time it
would be a really good gift brand could
give to Aria on their reunion thank you
so much those are some of my thoughts
about Aria going into season seven and
again if you want to check out more of
my stuff check out Phil the issues guy
here on YouTube and huge thanks for
having me here in this channel it could
be a great season the game of Thrones
hey guys this is Chris from smokescreen
and first off Dan thank you for having
me back on talking Thrones really
appreciate the opportunity so let's talk
about some season 7 predictions and talk
about what's going to happen with
Melisandre and I got to say right off
the bat I'm kind of worried about
Melisandre the first thing that worried
me is that she's going to be at kind of
Thrones now she did end up canceling
that but she was going to be there kind
of Thrones and every single other actor
that played on Game of Thrones there was
already dead in the show so that kind of
bothered me a bit although originally
she was not scheduled to be on the panel
with all the dead characters so I don't
know I'm not really sure if that plays
into it but it did worry me a bit that
she was going to be there but the point
being is that that kind of bothered me
because I wasn't really sure if she was
going to make it to season 8 so anyway
there's a couple things we do know we do
know from the trailer now she does make
it to Dragonstone so that's very very
important here because we know that from
the previous season that Melisandre and
Arya had this little meeting when they
were in the Riverlands with the
Brotherhood without banners
and this is when Melisandre of course
came to take Gendry because he wanted to
burn him alive the good thing for Gendry
Stannis wanted a little bit of proof and
therefore she did the little leeching
trick to show how powerful King's blood
was and of course Kendra is Robert
Baratheon son and does have King's blood
in his veins and of course we know that
means Valyrian blood anyway this is a
very very important scene because she
does tell Arya
we will meet again she kind of took the
ghost of how Hart's thing in the books
where she sees that darkness and aura
she says she sees blue eyes and green
eyes etc that she's going to close
forever and of course that pointed to
Arya becoming a faceless man over in
Braavos with Jack and the GAR but the
point being here that I do think this is
going to happen now Melisandre did get
put on arias list because she took
Gendry so that is the big question of
course when they meet again which I
think they will in season 7 will Oreo
try to kill Melisandre now of course
Melisandre probably has a few tricks up
her sleeve she's not going to be easily
killed she is a pretty damn powerful
witch regardless if you believe there's
actually a real or red god whatever or
it's just magical stuff she's learned
through the prism of religion the point
being here is she's not going to be a
pushover
but Ari is also a dangerous [ __ ]
too so initially I thought the Aria may
come across Melisandre in the Riverlands
you may take her out she may not make it
through season 8 since John has now
banished her and of course that happened
last year when John found out from Davos
that Melisandre had burned Shireen Davos
wanted to have her killed immediately
but John didn't really know the full
story and she thought she was doing it
for a bigger reason to save the damn
world so Jon basically banished her from
the north and last week's alt Melisandre
she was riding south on a horse and of
course she's heading right in the
direction of Arya who is still in the
Riverlands after she took care of Walder
Frey and make some damn Frey pie and of
course there's a reminder last year in
season six the Brotherhood without
banners is now heading north with the
Hound and I definitely think there's
going to be a Hound Aria reunion or a
Gendry or a reunion or both for that
matter so I think that's a perfect
opportunity for them to be heading north
perhaps Arya meets up with the
Brotherhood without banners she's the
one that kind of lets them know what's
going on up north that makes her decide
to go home to Winterfell because we do
know from the trailers she does go home
to Winterfell and that would be the
perfect opportunity for her to meet
Melisandre again and the perfect
opportunity for her to mark her off her
list but the conundrum comes in now is
that we now we see the trailers we see
Melisandre staring down as somebody as
they come up through Dragonstone and of
course that's a lot further southeast
than the Riverlands so she has to make
it to Dragonstone but the question is
does she come out of Dragonstone alive
now we're not really sure in the trailer
it looks like she's watching Danni
perhaps come up the steps or it actually
may be Jon and Douglas when they come to
Dragonstone to meet Danny for the first
time so that wouldn't indicate that
Melisandre is already at Dragonstone
when Danny arrives and I'm going to
guess that's going to be in season 7
episode 1 as in next looking sunday
finally after a year in a damn half so
if she makes it all the way down to
Dragonstone further south in the
Riverlands obviously Arya will not kill
her so how can we have it both ways how
does Melisandre make it all the way to
Dragonstone which is further south in
the Riverlands and have her in Oriya
cross paths and Arya doesn't actually
kill her well one of two things either
they meet she recognizes Melisandre
Melisandre of course she would remember
Arya and they meet and have a discussion
and she talks about all the things
that's happened up north during her time
across the Narrow Sea and Bravo's trying
to become a faceless man and she tells
her that John is alive and well and
Sansa there in Winterfell and that may
sure want to go home she tells her
perhaps about John being resurrected he
is the prince that was promised and
always like okay I appreciate you
helping out my brother I won't [ __ ]
kill you now so that's certainly a
possibility but the other thing is is
the actress
Carice van Houten I believe if I'm
pronouncing that right er hoot and I'm
not really sure anyway the actress that
plays Melisandre sent out a picture on
her Instagram account many many months
ago showing her back in the old crone
makeup and I do believe that was for
season seven I don't think she would put
something out that was from Season six
because we did see what happens when she
takes off that damn choker and stops
taking her damn medication so I think
Arya and Melisandre will meet again only
Arya will not recognize her this time
because she will have removed the choker
and stopped taking her potions and
that's how they could get by each other
even have a conversation without Arya
knowing actually who it is therefore
they can have a meeting they can meet
again and fulfill that little prophecy
so to speak the Melisandre could also
make it all the way down to Dragonstone
so I do think Melisandre will have a
role to play as far as kind of filling
in Arya on what the hell's been going on
in the north and more importantly to
Arya what the hell's been going on with
John and that he is alive and he is
resurrected and he is and her eyes the
print that was promised very very
important to the end game of our story
which will make Arya want to kind of go
home and stop going on her killing spree
because I'm thinking with Arya that she
would like to leave the Riverlands and
go straight to King's Landing to take
out Cersei but something has to get her
back on the path of rejoining her Wolf
Pack so to speak and heading home to
Winterfell so the question is of course
what the hell happens once Melisandre
makes it to Dragonstone she goes down to
Dragonstone which does make sense if you
think about it because this was a
Baratheon hild Castle this is where
Stannis was holed up the entire time
before he went on his conquest so it
makes complete sense that she would be
there the question is of what happens
when Danny gets there she's already
there and will she hang out with Denny
and kind of be up her ass or does she
still believe jon is the prince that was
promised once she sees Dany and fire
made flesh as in three [ __ ] dragons
so I think that's certainly a
possibility that she hangs out with Dany
a little bit and tries to discover
what's going on with her because she's
never heard of her she's never seen
these dragons it may shake her
confidence in her own damn religion a
bit more because she already thinks jon
is the prince that was promised but now
she's going to see this Dany character
with fire made flesh real [ __ ]
dragons and she's going to be a bit
confused
but what happens when John and obelisk
go through Dragonstone and see
Melisandre there if that happens at all
I think that's a big possibility we do
know John's going to head south from the
trailers he's going to meet Danny the
first time and Davos is going to be with
him being his right-hand man and they
run into Melisandre they're now John
wouldn't necessarily have any pull
they're on Dragonstone since that's
Danny's castle
so John probably wouldn't and probably
couldn't have her executed other Douglas
would probably still like to do that
himself
but then again I could see a scene where
Jon and Douglas walk in to talk to Danny
for the first time or the first couple
times during their visits at Dragonstone
middle sandra's there and they tell
Danny what actually happened and Danny
considering herself the new queen of
Westeros could actually dish out
punishment to Melisandre and kill her
and I think this is actually the perfect
death for her I don't want her to die I
do want to play a bigger role in the end
game of our story but she could die by
fire and I think that would be the
perfect ending especially if it's Dragon
Fire so I'm not saying that's going to
happen or I wanted to happen because I
do think that she has a bigger role to
play in the end game because don't
forget we did see in a previous season
when Stannis and then went to attack
King's Landing at the Battle of
Blackwater all those men died in that
wildfire Davos had talked Stannis into
leaving Milla saunder behind and when
they get back to Dragonstone Milla
Saunders said she could have saved those
men what does that actually mean and
does that mean something's going to
happen in the end game of our story with
Melisandre being involved in the great
war where she's not actually left behind
this time did that actually mean
something what could she have done to
save those men that help Stannis win
that war like she said would happen if
she was there since Tyrion had the whole
wildfire trick up his sleeve so anyway
that's kind of my overview of what I
think is going to happen in season 7 I'm
really torn between Melisandre actually
living through season 7 and making it
the season 8 because I do think she
could play a role in the end game
because of the whole Blackwater
reference but I could also see Danny
actually punishing her you know dishing
out the new Queens justice after John
and Davos tailed Danny what she did even
though she thought she was doing it for
a good reason
and I've also mentioned this in quite a
few live streams I wanted to see the
king of aura of Melisandre meeting which
may or may not happen I don't know if
the King vara actress is going to be
back in season 7 whatsoever but I wanted
to see a red priestess from Essos who
believes Danny as the prince that was
promised or the princess that was
promised come over and meet Melisandre
who thinks jon is the prince that was
promised I wanted them to come together
and has a [ __ ] mud wrestling
to argue over who the actual prince that
was promised is or if they could agree
that they both were or whatever I just
wanted to see that interaction but I
don't think we're going to see that
unfortunately because I don't think
Kenmore is going to come over with Danny
to Westeros I want to thank each and
every person that contributed to this
video gray area order of the green hand
secrets of the Citadel smokescreen
bridge for ideas of Ice and Fire
Tony Teflon game of theories bat
productions Phil the issues guy and
because geek I really appreciate all of
you reaching back out to me and joining
the collaboration when I got the idea to
make a video like this I wasn't really
sure what kind of response I would get
because there were a few of you that I
had never spoken to before but you all
are really cool people and reached back
out to me anyway to collab and I respect
that and thank you for that if anyone is
interested in checking out any of these
channels other work all of their links
are down in the description they each
make their own interesting and unique
content over on their respective
channels that I would recommend checking
out when you can I want to thank
everyone else for stopping by and
watching this video especially if you
listened all the way until the end there
is only two days left until episode 1
premieres and I can't wait to finally
watch some new episodes and discuss them
all with you I'm not sure if I'm going
to release anything tomorrow or not but
I'll definitely see you after the
premiere before I go I want to thank the
supporters of this channel that are on
patreon your generosity means a lot to
me and this channel I love you all and
I'll see you down below in the comment
section bye